- Well, financially, I think people
are very confused about my narrative.
People think I was handed,
I love it when people troll me.
"He was handed," I was handed nothing.
I don't own Wine library.
Financially, it was the other way.
Financially, I gassed my parents up.
That's facts.
I went in, spent 14 years.
I never paid myself.
That's the impact that
I had on the business.
What I deserved.
Because I invested in the business.
And I left the 34 with
no money to my name.
(relaxed music)
But, emotionally, they put me so on,
because I thought I was unstoppable.
And, experientially, my dad put me on
by giving me autonomy to run a business.
So, it was a trade, right?
(slow music)
Yes, so lets just do
everything here at 7:00.
And have me done by like 9:30.
- [Interviewer] If someone wasn't raised
in that environment,
with that self-belief,
how does one develop that for themselves?
- Surrounding themselves by
people that do it for them,
or consuming content
that does it for them.
Penetrating people's skulls,
and fucking reframing their game.
Their fucking mom told
them they were a loser,
I'm telling them they're a winner.
I think I can out-market their mom.
Their mom had a big head
start at a whole lot
of emotional, fucking
physiological advantages,
but guess what?
Give me fucking 18 months of your time,
give me two hours a day,
I'll make you realize, fuck your mom.
And go do your thing.
That's what I'm up to.
(electronic music)
Hey guys, it's Gary.
I say to myself, I suck.
But I don't let any of you say I suck.
You know, subcultures can call
themselves a certain thing,
but nobody else can.
You can fucking make fun of your brother,
but if somebody else does,
you punch them in the fucking mouth.
That's how I think about
the creative process.
It's a very interesting fine line.
I'm going to hold myself
accountable, but that's me with me.
You are actually the judge.
You, as a collective, is number one.
Me to myself is number two.
A distant third, which I can't even hear,
is an individual giving me feedback.
I think my game is very reversed
from everybody else's, creatively.
All of you is number one., the market.
I only care about your
motherfuckers, as a collective,
so I'm just putting out.
It's the creative, strategic
framework that I have,
that is absolutely fucking right.
(upbeat music)
I think you guys should
build a media company.
I don't think you should advertise.
I think you should build bar stool,
instead of being a media creative output.
Fundamentally, I believe,
a decade from now,
every company is going to realize they're
in the publishing business,
they're in the media business.
They'll be thinking about their OTT.
The Red Bulls, and the Pepsi's,
they'll be thinking about
owning an OTT outright.
I think our kind of companies,
not to that trillion
levels yet, on our way,
are going to be thinking
about becoming the bar stools,
and the Refinery 29's,
and whatever it may be.
I think that's the number
one thing I would invest in.
- Thank you, nice to meet you.
- It's a pleasure.
- Good to meet you, thank you.
- [Tom] Hey, how's it going?
- Such a pleasure.
- [Tom] Tom, nice to meet you.
- How's it going, brother?
- [Gary] How's it going,
brother, how are you?
- What's going on, I'm all right.
Real, the date right there, early.
It's tremendous.
Fuck, it's amazing, great job.
- [Tom] Thanks, Judy.
- Super pumped, it's a
great piece of content.
I think literally putting
the date a little earlier,
I think, will win that
three-second Facebooking
that I care so much about.
Other than that, man,
that was fucking tremendous storytelling.
- Nice to meet you.
- Great to see you.
Thank you guys.
(upbeat music)
- [Interviewer] Do you have a
strategy to staying present?
- No, man, that's,
if there was strategy behind
that, it wouldn't work.
It's who I am.
So, I was about the say,
I'm the CO of a big company,
I've got this profile, but it's not true.
When I was 22 years old,
and I had nine employees at Wine library
and I was trying to build this business,
if I sat down with
somebody for 15 minutes,
even though I had a lot going on,
because it seemed like a lot at the time,
it was my a lot, just like
they have their a lot,
you have your a lot, right?
I think I work for somebody else.
And so when we sat down,
whether it's somebody like you
that had some context from me before,
and think its really cool,
or some people like, right,
my CO's got fans or something, right?
And sits down, I'm in that
meeting for that person.
It's less about strategy,
it's about thoughtfulness.
I'm thoughtful more than,
that it's this crazy strategy.
One added layer of human
psychology in the current state
that I think you're
tapping into fashion-wise.
All the powers and restrictions,
it's why Snapchat won.
I think one of the things
you should consider is
only available from 2:00 AM to 6:00 AM.
Make it impossible.
(people muttering agreement)
I'm obsessed with restrictions.
Like, only available 2:00AM to 6:00AM.
That's fucking terrible,
no, that's the worst--
- [Woman] Shackle.
(laughing)
- But exactly why it's
right, in my opinion.
All the answers are in the no.
All the answers.
And it's so authentic to
where your brand's positioned.
I think resources are going to run out.
I will say this.
The high low of influencers, I think,
is going to be your pay dirt.
So to me, the holy grail
is GG and Yung Baby Tate.
- [Woman] Mm-hmm.
- [Man] Who's Yung Baby Tate?
- She's just a real cool, like fuck it.
- Is that Lil Tay, is that
who you're talking about?
- No, no Lil Tay's ridiculous.
Look her up, Yung Baby Tay, right?
She's like in Atlanta,
fuck it she wears like,
she looks like she's Avril
Lavigne, but she's black.
And she can really sing,
and she's in Atlanta.
And she's 15 months away from
21 Savage putting her on a feature.
And, you know, 22 months
from now, she's famous.
And then I get to recall
that I mentioned her,
and be like, "Look how I
was on before all of you."
Her, right, she's a 14.4 right now.
♪ You in my vicinity. ♪
♪ 'Bout to pack up, moving up to Italy. ♪
- Here's what's great about her.
I have no idea how you
guys would filter fashion,
that's where you know.
Here's what I know, she's
going to be a big star.
All right, I'm going to be late as fuck,
and my wife is going
to punch me in my neck.
- Thank you for your time.
- Thank you so much.
- You're welcome.
- It's nice to meet you, Gary.
- A real pleasure.
(upbeat music)
Hey brother, how are you?
Dude, happiness is the fucking ROI.
Not checking some arbitrary,
back to the delusion and ego thing
that you and I just talked about.
Knowing what you're going to do
for the rest of your life at 30.
Or being out of the house by 30.
Or having your shit together by 30.
Or fucking being married by 30.
Or having a kid by 30,
that's fucking horseshit.
And as long as you don't
fucking spend your money
on fancy shit on the outside, right?
As long as you don't get,
the key is when you get a developer job,
and you get paid $150,
that you don't live a
lifestyle that's based on 150,
then if you don't want to then be a cook,
and you can only make
78, you're fucking stuck,
and you end up being a
developer for your whole life.
Even though you fucking hated it.
Because you needed to be
able to pay your rent,
and your fucking lifestyle.
The reason I never needed the
fancy car, or fancy apartment,
or fancy clothes, or fancy
things, or go to fancy places,
was because I didn't yearn for them,
and I definitely wasn't going
to do them for somebody else.
I think most people do
shit for other people.
I think most people buy the car,
and the house, for other people.
Dude, some people love
the leather of a car,
or the horsepower, yes.
Do some people love having a home
that has nine rooms they never use, sure.
But do you understand?
- [Interviewer] Mm-hmm.
(pop music)
- I think once you own your weaknesses,
and once you tap into emotions,
you become unstoppable.
The reason I want to talk
about all these insecurities,
is once you own it, it goes
completely the other way.
Like, maybe its the best.
It's like the last scene of 8 Mile.
Right, I need you to talk about the fact
that you're scared shitless.
Hey bro, I need you to understand
that the reason you bought a Rolex,
is because you think you
need it to bang a chick.
(pop music)